(latin music)
- You can walk into my office
with any type of case,
and I can handle it, no matter what it is.
We don't give up.
- [Narrator] This is Jay J. Armes,
and he's maybe the world's most
famous private investigator.
- I don't say that I am.
People say that I am.
- [Narrator] Back in 1958,
Armes founded The Investigators.
- [Jay] The Investigators is a company
that was established by Jay Armes
to conduct every type of investigation.
We cover the whole spectrum.
(cool music)
- [Narrator] And like all
legendary heroic figures,
Jay has triumphed over tragedy.
- When I was 11 years old,
a friend came over to my home,
had a box of dynamite caps,
they exploded, had blown
my hands off at the wrist.
- [Narrator] So young Jay was outfitted
with prosthetics, and he managed to
turn a
- turn a negative
into a positive.
- [Narrator] Exactly.
(soft, quick music)
Here's Jay J. Armes petting his
white Siberian Tiger, Simba.
And here he is with his
53-year-old pet chimp, Gypsy.
And here's Gypsy with Jay's son, Jay.
So Jay, how many cases have you solved?
- Hundreds of cases,
all over the world.
- [Narrator] Can you be a
little bit more specific?
- [Jay] You ask an artist,
how many paintings have you done?
He can't tell you, I've done
20 paintings or 200 paintings.
I take my craft like an artist.
- [Narrator] And he's had
some pretty famous clientele.
(cool music)
- [Jay] Most famous case
was Marlon Brando.
He says, Jay, somebody has
kidnapped my son Christian.
He gave me the information where
the boy was kidnapped from.
- [Narrator] Legend has
it that Jay J. Armes
tracked down Christian
to the jungles of Mexico,
flying his helicopter and
staying up for five days
without food or water,
until he came upon a camp
with eight armed men.
- I heard him coughing in a little tent.
I went into the little tent,
and there was Christian Brando.
He didn't know me.
He sees this guy with two hooks,
so he thought I was one of the bad guys.
I said, no, no.
Your father hired me.
(soft guitar music)
- [Narrator] For Jay J. Armes,
what was once an impediment
has become an asset,
and has led to a long, fruitful career.
- [Jay] I been doin' this type of work
for over 45 years.
- [Narrator] How old are you, Jay?
- Oh, I'm 'bout 150.
- [Narrator] At 150,
- But I'm really not 150.
- [Narrator] At not 150, it's safe to say
most of Jay J. Armes'
adventures are behind him.
But he's not slowin' down any time soon.
- [Jay] No, I have more
work now than ever.
- [Narrator] Jay, do you
see yourself as a legend?
How do you wanna be remembered?
- On my obituary, "Jay
Armes did it his way."
One-liner, and that's it.
(lilting guitar music)